this game like life requires forethought
so that's not about where you are where
you will be in 10 moves or 10 years
our attack how that even happened that
was in better shape than either of us
yeah there's something I need to discuss
with you what is it your father left
this for you
[Music]
and you alone does any daughter really
know her father
show me your face Lauren Elizabeth
Montero you're not like him I suspect
you're better than he ever was
who are you I'd like to think I'm a
member of the family
are there any old enemies of dads that I
should be aware of they both know he was
no saint someone was threatening our
family dumped his body in the river
you said you could have the truth I know
things I'll take to the grave give me
what I asked for and I will tell you
everything
you think this is a game
what else was my dad hiding a lawyer a
banker a politician who'd you talk to
we found the Holy Trinity the father had
no right to do what he did
all right the family
when all is said and done you will know
the truth
and you will send me free
the truth must stay buried
you